here's Philips good deep crush towards
the far post in an attempt to make them
more realistic both peasant FIFA slowed
down in recent years until now it's a
trend that's harmed the eighth series
with every title since FIFA 15 feeling
less responsive than its predecessor
finally with fee 418 the franchise has
stopped the rock and while this latest
century still feels slow it does feel
more responsive and less frustrating as
a result combined with outstanding
presentation are more ways to play than
ever the fray teens on pitch
improvements represent the beginnings of
a recovery for the series
[Applause]
so much attacking confidence another
goal there to up now all the prospects
here are of war goals to come p-47 teens
problem was that is slowed players
turning speeds to Titanic levels but
left much of the rest of the game at a
high of velocity that meant you could
still sprint pretty quickly but would
take an age to accelerate or change
direction this is still a problem in
FIFA 18 where players continued slow
turning circles and lengthy animations
can make it fill out there's a
split-second of input lag but as slower
sprinting does mean the game speed as a
whole feels more consistent this results
in a more thoughtful game but it's less
concerned with beating defenders using
trickery or pace and more about letting
the ball do the work AI teammates now
make more frequent and more intelligent
runs to give you greater options when
you're on the ball and players first
touches keep the ball closer to their
body finally making driven passes a
viable option in the attacking third
unfortunately non-driven passes remain
as limp as before long passes and chip
through walls still slowly flow towards
their target before inevitably getting
cut out and ground passes are similarly
weak rarely possessing enough zip to
carve a defense open on the other hand
shots carry a little more weight than
before and are responsible for the
game's most satisfying moments seeing a
volley fly into the top corner is a
great feeling and it happens far more
frequently in fee 4:18 than last year
crosses have also been reworked and now
they whip across the face of goal with a
bit more pace it's now much easier to
score by crossing it into the box and
doing so feels great set pieces are
still pretty useless though and they're
Nayan impossible to score from
how's it go here and the goalkeeper
pangs are well there are a number of
lingering floors holding FIFA back
different players still don't feel
unique enough other than Ronaldo and a
handful more of the world's elite every
footballer in the game feels roughly the
same and the vast majority of them
display the same animations and only
feel different in their Heights and
speed stats this year's giving quick
subs which allow you to substitute a
player without having to pause the game
but they're limited by the fact that you
can only apply it to three pre-planned
changes organized before the match plus
I was constantly activating it by
accident because it's map to the same
button this sprint if fee Frei teens on
the pitch showing is inconsistent its
presentation continues to set the
standard for sports games everywhere
prettier and more versatile lighting
helps make each match feel unique and
that's aided by more realistic and more
enthusiastic crowd reactions in
different kinds of atmosphere depending
on where in the world you're playing
Spanish matches are scored with a
distant beat of drums and constant noise
whereas English crowds are more likely
to taunt the away team over their lack
of support club specific chants are
common for the bigger sites the
Liverpool fans may tire after unfilled
to 200th rendition of you'll never walk
alone
then there's official league specific
branding and graphics lineups being read
out by stadium announcers and the
largely excellent commentators
discussing real-life transfers and
results together they make a game that
replicates the experience of watching
football and interprets the culture
around the sport better than ever
hi there Martin walking into the ground
today I've just got that feeling feeling
it's going to be a really good afternoon
one of the best games I've seen in
recent times the greatest tribute for
the German Super Cup Ashley and Dortmund
be buying for two but you know could
have been easily there for two the other
way spell by as FIFA continues to almost
become a sports channel in itself it
also expands its repertoire of game
modes every year this year sees the
narrative driven journey mode return for
a second season with Alex hunter now a
world famous prodigy the journey sees
few improvements over season 1 beyond
some greater customization options this
class produces the same mixed
performances as last year
it remains a unique mode but think of
FIFA 18 journey more similar to the
second run of a middling TV show than
anything else it's the same just more of
it elsewhere pro clubs remains largely
untouched say for a journey style skill
tree in which you need to acquire
certain traits before others are
unlocked an ultimate team's winning
formula has also mostly been left alone
the few new additions include squad
battles where you play a number of
matches against other Ultimate Team
clubs controlled by AI before being
ranked against other real world players
for they might have windy manage they're
perfect for those who don't want to
brave the wastelands of online
multiplayer or for those who don't have
the time to commit the latter's grueling
schedule of qualification rounds and
weekend tournaments daily objectives are
another new feature there awti with
coins or packs for say winning by over
two goals or for scoring with a ser er
player they offer welcome new bonuses
particularly for seasons players who
have traditionally been granted meek of
rewards finally career modes transfer
negotiations have been overhauled
instead of submitting your offer as an
email transfer talks are now conducted
in real time through interactive
cutscenes
it's a largely superficial change since
the only actual new feature is the
ability to add release clauses and
sellon percentages to player contracts
the rest of the process is exactly the
same still seeing a human face rather
than a written letter live-ins the mode
off a little otherwise career mode is
the same as ever with the player
conversation system feeling the most
stale the emails players sense you are
identical to the ones they've been
sending for years now and there's still
no way to reply changes to career mode
pro clubs and Ultimate Team are Maya but
that's largely because what was already
there was excellent they each offer a
different way to play with career mode
offering chance to control your favorite
team pro clubs being a great way to play
with your friends and free t4 ultimate
team being by far the most addictive and
satisfying especially for those who
collected football cards as a kid so
it's off the pitch that EA excels from
the variety of game modes on offer and
how everything is presented to the
constant updates
efore ultimate teams team of the week
daily objectives and discussion of real
worlds happening in commentary fee for
18 captures the world of football and
confidently translates it into a video
game
on the pitch however EA Soccer series is
still lagging far behind PES 2018 s more
fluid satisfying football this years
improvements are welcome but more needs
to be done in the coming years
a fee for us to be a world beater once
again
[Applause]
it's very stylish Mandy
advantage at last worked hard to get it
this way they're celebrating
[Applause]